so um I'm going to talk about an old
idea that
um actually was brought up by Churchill
in 1932 in his book uh thoughts and
Adventures where he said well you know
why grow a whole chicken if you only eat
the breast in the wing and he got the
idea and of course not completely by
himself he was befriended with Alexis
Carell the Nobel prize-winning
physiologist who kept organs alive for
the first time ever outside of the body
um
and
so to introduce the concept of what we
were trying to do to make meat out of
cultured wardens or cells here's a
question for you video for you how much
meat does our world eat
in just one day
the numbers are alarming all the more
because current production methods will
not be able to meet future demand if you
include the crops grown for animals to
eat currently more than 70 percent of
all arable land is occupied by livestock
[Music]
also keeping livestock for food produces
significant amounts of greenhouse gases
such as methane and carbon dioxide
[Music]
foreign
pigs and cows transform only 15 percent
of vegetable proteins into edible animal
proteins and to produce one kilogram of
beef up to 15 000 liters of water is
required
in the near future both meat and other
staple foods are likely to become
expensive luxury items
the World Health Organization recently
estimated that demand for meat is going
to double in the next 40 years
but a pioneering new technology is being
developed that offers a solution to all
those problems and this is how it works
[Music]
first muscle tissue is harvested by
biopsy in a small and harmless procedure
next the biopsy is cut into minuscule
pieces to separate the muscle fibers and
cells now let's take a closer look at
this tissue through the microscope
[Music]
of fat cells and muscle cells both of
which are used to produce cultured meat
[Music]
by dissecting the muscle cells stem
cells are harvested and cultured the
cells start dividing
eventually from one muscle stem cell
more than one trillion stem cells can be
grown
these cells naturally merge together to
form so-called myotubes which are no
longer than 0.3 millimeters
[Music]
the muscle is then grown by lining them
up between two velcro anchor points
muscles in a tendency to contract causes
it to put on bulk growing into a small
piece of muscle tissue
[Music]
from one small piece of tissue this
pioneering technique can produce more
than a trillion strands
[Music]
when all of these little pieces of
muscle are then layered together and
combined with cultured pieces of fat you
actually get exactly the same product as
we started with
meat
[Music]
but there's more to this meat than meets
the eye the technology has some healthy
benefits too it allows control over the
level of fat content it can eradicate
human disease contracted from livestock
and the meat can be given the perfect
balance of necessary nutrients
what's more the technique benefits the
environment too
it can lead the way to cruelty-free meat
with a production process that is
environmentally friendly providing a
sustainable meat Source ready for the
demands of the future
the end result is meat exactly as we
know it but produced in a far more
efficient sustainable and
animal-friendly way as new methods are
found to scale up production cultured
beef could be on its way to a dinner
plate near you
okay so um if this is true where would
gelatin then come from because the
gelatin the other person that you are
using is coming from animal bones and
that's by far the largest production
system so um when we start producing
meat a different way and and get rid of
at least most of the animals then
gelatin would become a scarce item so
you should look for another gig I guess
I suggest to use agar
instead anyway for
um meat being produced is where you've
now seen the reasons why there are
important reasons to do this not many
people realize it but we are facing a
meat crisis very quickly now
so there are important reasons to do
this and there is a technology that is
capable of replacing meat production uh
albeit that we are still far away from
getting into a dinner plate near you in
fact at the end of November we will have
the first hamburger which costs about
250 thousand Euro to
technicians of mine have worked on that
for about three months growing 40
billion cells
and um so it's it's still quite a labor
intensive and not very efficient process
but for it to succeed we figured that
there were two major items it needs to
be efficient you have seen that the
animals are very inefficient so we need
to be more efficient and it needs to
mimic meat we have meat substitutes
Galore
um but there is some craving in us that
wants to really eat meat so we need to
make meat and not a substitute
so in order to make it efficient there
are a lot of variables that you can work
with and we have tried a fair number of
them you can work with the culture
medium with the we have to get rid of
the serum eventually which is doable we
have already shown that but it's it
still needs a little bit of work you
need to go quicker from 2D to 3D culture
and you can use potentially salt water
algae to feed the cells because we still
need to feed the cells currently for
this hamburger we need 60 billion cells
which is 200 of these flasks these
plastic flags that are non-recyclable 10
layers with with cells and we need 200
of those which fit in a large incubator
and if you stick to this process which
we're using right now eventually for
every 10 people you would need a 25 000
liter which is a big swimming pool
incubator to accommodate that
so this is our incubator right now with
all these Flats of cells these these 60
billion cells that we are growing and
this is just to point out this time this
guy is four times as big as this one and
this contains actually much more cells
because this is now the 3D tissue those
strips that you saw in in the movie that
we are harvesting freezing and then
glued together to form a a hamburger
so we do need to uh to feed them sugars
proteins and fatty acids which gives
which is mentioned also in the video the
opportunity to play a little bit with it
and to maybe even make healthier meat
and with polyunsaturated fatty acids or
we could use salt water algae to grow
them and the first factory could for
instance be at the mouth of the
Mississippi where there is an algae Dead
Zone we just fish out all the algae out
of the ocean and feed it to ourselves
and if you do that and there are a lot
of assumptions here you can reduce the
number of the amount of water and land
and energy tremendously
by producing the meat this way so we
also need to make it really like meat
and nothing else not really a substitute
so we need to think about taste color
and texture mouth feel if you like
that's not going to be very easy one
nice thing about these cells is that
they organize the tissue themselves so
we don't need to do a whole lot about
them if you put them in a gel
in between two anchor points after 24
hours they have built a muscle in
between those anchor points and they
will start to bulk up protein and they
will start to contract actually and
start to look really like muscle
of course you can also zap them
electrically stimulate them which is not
very energy efficient I admit but then
under the microscope it looks exactly
like a skeletal muscle fiber so you can
mimic the exact same tissue in vitro
and of course we are conditioning them
in various ways to get from this animal
to this one
uh this by the way is a blonde blue
belch which is a cow that has a natural
mutation that was discovered by the
belgiums uh just after the world war and
they decided to breed with it and it has
a mutation in myostatin which limits the
um myostatin usually limits the protein
production by muscle cells the
hypertrophy by muscle cells so if you
don't have that you get these animals
which is not very natural they cannot
give birth naturally so you need to do
cesarean section but now 95 percent of
all the meat in Belgium is taken from
these well this is a bull but from these
animals
and we are taking actually the stem
cells from to see whether we can this is
a Contracting muscle
so if you it contracts by itself but if
you stimulate it IT contract a little
bit more and it starts to make more
protein so you get better to the area
where you need to be to the real meat
these are these strands in between two
velcro strips by the way also from the
local Tesco
um and uh so they develop in about three
weeks in between those trips and then we
Harvest them right now we actually grow
them in Donuts so we don't even eat a
velcro anymore
but it's the same principle they need
these anchor points to bulk up protein
and of course they are still pretty
white there's no blood in there
um the the red in blood is hemoglobin
when it's exposed to oxygen and in
muscle actually there's not really a
whole lot of blood and uh but there is
myoglobin which is a protein that's very
similar to hemoglobin and it turns red
when exposed to oxygen and if you just
grow these cells under low oxygen
conditions you get a five-fold increase
in myoglobin production so you can play
with color with all these variables all
these culture variables to get to a
product that um eventually is the same
as as meat we also it was reported that
you could add caffeine so coffee to
these hamburgers which would be great
because you would stay awake after a
hamburger some people
couldn't eat them at night of course but
but unfortunately it didn't really
improve the biographical concentration a
lot so we forgot about that idea
and you might think you know it's not
only muscle meat it's also fat and it's
a bone maybe and it's
even bone marrow can you make that as
well of course we can actually
um
fat has already been grown we know what
to do how to how to grow that this is a
this is not an experiment by ourselves
but from somebody else who in four weeks
grew a tiny piece of
fat from fat stem cells
and this is our own example where all
the the red stuff is all fed from
adipose tissue derived stem cells from
that same biopsy
um so how are you going to produce it
well you could potentially produce it in
your own kitchen
these stem cells that we use that
replicate
they survive freeze drying so you could
order your little bag of this is salmon
a bag of stem cells from any animal or
Creature from the internet and then
start to grow your meat in your own
kitchen of course you need to know six
weeks in advance what you're going to
eat because it takes a while
but it's doable so one of the big
questions is who is going to eat this
and if you ask people in the Streets of
London so randomly you know are you
going to eat meat from a factory or from
a laboratory they say you know are you
kidding me
um but if you rephrase that question and
well you know let's see 20 30 23 years
from now he would hit the supermarket
and you see these two products in the in
the Shell on the shelves and they are
exactly the same and they taste the same
and the quality is the same but this is
the the real thing it's now four times
as expensive because it has an Ecotec
and there's this nasty label on it that
animals have suffered for that product
and it's exactly the same and the price
is right what are you going to do right
um and I think it will eventually be
um that will be a problem that can be
conquered there are a couple of other
issues of course we need to
industrialize it scale it up which is
quite a challenge
but it can be done
you can make them from different tissues
I've already shown that and then
eventually
um
this is where you end up
right you can with a complete clear
conscious keep eating your hamburger
thank you very much